le corona virus vient d'affecter nos
territoires d'outre-mer comme si nous
avions besoin de ça les territoires
d'outre-mer c'est déjà la cherté de la
vie c'est un chômage est un chômage
épouvantable et voilà maintenant que les
familles sont déstabilisés que les gens
ont peur et on comprend bien parce que
il y a à la fois la peur de la maladie
et puis il ya surtout la peur du
lendemain
alors il a fallu prendre le taureau par
les cornes
il faut bien qu'on commence à parler
maintenant de ce que sera demain en
matière économique de ce que sera demain
pour les familles pour les gens pour ce
qu'ils sont peut-être un peu plus
protégé mais pour ceux qui sont exposés
puis pour ceux qui sont extrêmement
exposées
voilà c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
décidé de m'adresser à vous en tant que
président des reds homme est de vous
proposer les solutions de l'association
toute l'équipe que je remercie et qui
travaillent dur pour trouver les
meilleurs moyens pour protéger les gens
pour que personne ne soit laissé sur le
bord du chemin
alors voilà l'économie dans les
territoires d'outre-mer tout le monde
connaît le problème c'est que on est
dans une économie de rente il faut être
assez clair ce qu'ils ont pris des
positions il ya déjà 25 30 40 et
beaucoup plus d'années encore nous
savons à peu près tous d'où ça vient on
aujourd'hui des positions qui sont des
positions qui sont hyper dominante et
ses positions hyper dominante font d'eux
des gens qui ont finalement tout raflé
la vraie question aujourd'hui avec cette
crise qui est une crise économique sans
précédent
est ce qu'il n'ya pas là enfin
l'opportunité à travers ce malheur de
recaler l'économie dans nos territoires
d'outre-mer pour faire en sorte que ça
ne soit pas toujours tous les mêmes qui
se partagent tous et enfin qu'on en
sorte avec une redistribution avec plus
d'égalité avec un capitalisme mais un
capitalisme tempéré où il n'y est pas
comme ça un partage qui est fait entre
quelques-uns entre quelques rafle tous
qu'ils attrapent toute la richesse des
territoires
l'argent doit pas toujours aller au même
et une fois de plus ceux qui ont tous
honte encore tout ça c'est pas possible
donc aujourd'hui l'état met en place un
système d'amortisseurs économique
c'est-à-dire le prêt garantie d'état et
on se rend compte déjà que ceux qui ont
l'habitude d'aller chercher des
subventions subvention européenne
d'aller chercher la défiscalisation
d'aller chercher les fonds de
compensation
une fois de plus ce sont encore les
mêmes qui ont te l'accès direct pour
aller chercher les prêts garanties
d'état alors quand ils en ont besoin
évidemment il faut le faire mais il ya
aussi celles qui n'ont pas
nécessairement besoin de ces prêts
garanties d'état mais qui vont quand
même les chercher d'abord parce que ce
sont des prêts très avantageux
évidemment que ça qu'on forme des
trésoreries qui parfois sont déjà
conforté au détriment de ceux qui n'ont
pas l'accès aux guichets et un grand
nombre d'entreprises aujourd'hui ne sont
pas taillés ne sont pas dimensionnés
pour aller chercher ces prêts et les
banquiers ont toujours les mêmes
réactions les banquets peut-on riches
c'est pas nouveau
et quand une entreprise arrive même dans
le cas d'un prêt garantie d'état à 90%
de garantie par l'état est bien même
dans un tel cas aujourd'hui il y a
encore une injustice qui est là parce
que une fois de plus c'est encore les
mêmes qui vont pouvoir tirer ses
sublimes ça franchement c'est
insupportable il faut tirer une leçon de
cette crise terrible
il faut changer de paradigme aujourd'hui
nous devons aller vers une équité on ne
peut plus continuer à donner une prime à
ceux qui ont tout ça c'est plus possible
les soutenir oui dans une juste mesure
certainement mais avoir véritablement un
soin tout particulier pour les
entreprises de plus petite taille tout
aussi et pour importante par la maîtrise
de leur savoir-faire par la maîtrise
qu'elles ont
de leur territoire de leur pays de ce
qu'elle y apporte de ce qu'elles ont
fabrique de manière endogène parce que
ces petites entreprises là elle fabrique
des choses sur place
elle n'apporte pas ses petites
entreprises c'est elle qu'il faut
soutenir et il faut les soutenir en
priorité
bien sûr tous les chiffres ne sont pas
encore remontés mais tous les socio
professionnels s'accordent à dire
qu'entre un tiers et 40% des entreprises
des territoires français d'outre-mer ne
sont pas à jour de leurs cotisations de
sécurité sociale ou de leurs impôts
alors ça les éloigne évidemment compte
tenu des critères mis par le
gouvernement de la capacité à récupérer
les amortisseurs économiques qui ont été
fabriquées pour elle et ça c'est très
injuste c'est très injuste pourquoi
parce que quand on a entre un tiers et
40% des entreprises qui n'ont pas payé
leurs charges sont pas jean dans un pot
c'est pas le fait d'une mauvaise gestion
c'est un fait beaucoup plus anciens
c'est le fait d'une accumulation souvent
on oublie cela mais les entreprises ont
traversé des crises on a connu une crise
terrible la crise des gilet jaune au à
la réunion c'est irma qui qui était qui
a secoué l'est
les antilles ça a été un moment donné
les 500 frères à la guyane etc etc
toutes ces crises là ont fragilisé le
tissu économique et ont fragilisé déjà
les plus fragiles alors aujourd'hui on
va pas en remettre une couche
on va pas en plus des difficultés qu'ils
ont subi pendant des années des années
leur faire grief de leur retard
aujourd'hui de leur dire vous êtes
certains ont plus rien pour vous ça
franchement on peut pas on peut pas
laisser des entreprises sur le chemin
donc moi ce que je dis aujourd'hui ce
que nous disons chez les red sommes
aujourd'hui c'est que il faut
aujourd'hui soutenir absolument ces
entreprises là au même titre qu'on
soutient les autres elles ont droit aux
subsides
la question n'est pas de savoir
aujourd'hui comment elles vont
rembourser les retards de paiement des
impôts ou les retards de paiement des
charges sociales
on verra ça après la crise mais au moins
il faut les aider à passer la période de
la crise et quant à celles qui ont
réussi jusqu'à maintenant malgré les
difficultés auxquelles elles ont été
confrontées comme les autres c'est
histoire de crises antérieures celles ci
il faut encore les encourager pour
qu'elle soit encore plus fort donc je
pense que dans un certain cas il faut
aider les entreprises qui vont vraiment
pas bien a passé ce moment difficile et
revoir avec elle dans quelques mois
quand ça ira mieux comment on peut les
aider à prendre un peu plus de poil de
la bête et comment on peut faire en
sorte qu'elles gagnent un peu plus
d'argent pour payer les retards
peut-être les retards qu'elles doivent
au moins de plus en accumuler dans
l'avenir et quant à celles qui ont
réussi parce qu'elle était sur des
marchés qui étaient des marchés un peu
plus solide celle ci peut être qu'il
faut les encourager encore en diminuant
peut-être à l'avenir leurs charges
pendant un certain temps pour les
musclés pour qu'elle aborde l'avenir
avec autre chose que simplement avoir
passé la période de la crise il faut pas
que passée la période de la crise il
faut ressortir plus fort de cette crise
et c'est ça tout le sens du partage
c'est ça tout le sens de ce que
j'appelle moi une économie tempéré une
économie qui n'est plus une économie des
rafles tous qui d'un côté ont tout pris
tout bouffer de l'économie
avec des profits colossaux et puis de
l'autre côté des entreprises absolument
bancal mais ces entreprises là fragile
parfois bancal ces entreprises c'est 90%
de l'économie de nos territoires
ces entreprises là c'est l'entreprise
qui fabrique de l'économie endogène
elle fabrique de l'économie locale elles
n'apportent pas elles elles produisent
de la richesse locale
alors on a le devoir premier de les
soutenir
c'est ça que nous disons chez air et
d'hommes
alors il y a aussi une catégorie
d'entrepreneurs qui est une catégorie
particulière ce sont bien des français
qui sont nos concitoyens qui sont en
guyane en martinique en guadeloupe
saint-martin saint-barth qui sont en
polynésie française à wallis et futuna
qui peuvent être aussi en nouvelle
calédonie comme dans l'océan indien à
mayotte ou à la réunion et ils ont tous
un point commun cela c'est que ils ont
des petites entreprises mais ces petites
entreprises là et bien elles ne sont pas
déclarés c'est ce qu'on appelle la main
d'oeuvre souterraines c'est ce qu'on
appelle là le travail dissimulé
franchement quelle hypocrisie tout le
monde sait tout le monde c'est-à-dire
aussi bien l'administration que le
politique que le monde économique c'est
que ces entreprises existent qu'elles
sont en nombre extrêmement importants et
ces entreprises là aujourd'hui sont
considérés comme la variable
d'ajustement et d'un système économique
qui a besoin d'elle parce que finalement
elle avance sans payer sans faire payer
trop cher et en même temps elles sont la
variable d'ajustement de la paix sociale
et on dit finalement que ben c'est la
soupape c'est la soupape de sécurité de
la paix sociale vous comprenez sont des
gens qui touchent des subsides sociaux
le rsa ou d'autres subsides sociaux et
puis qui en même temps bref en un peu de
travail à côté alors on ferme les yeux
là dessus parce que on considère que si
on touche à cette catégorie de gens
alors on va enflammer complètement les
territoires d'outre-mer
mais voilà mais pourquoi est-ce qu'on va
les enflammer fondamentalement parce que
ce serait pas faux c'est parce que
précisément ils apportent un service
fondamental aujourd'hui à l'économie des
territoires d'outre-mer et que leurs
actions sur le plan économique est une
action qui est une action indispensable
donc ce qu'il faut faire aujourd'hui
c'est les régulariser il faut
régulariser
nos concitoyens qui sont aujourd'hui
exclues du monde de la cotisation c'est
à dire que ce sont les premiers à en
souffrir
lorsqu'ils vont vieillir et on connaît
bien le problème dans des territoires
vieillissant comme malheureusement la
martinique ou la guadeloupe où là les
gens arrivent au terme d'une vie de
travail de labeur et n'ont pas droit à
la retraite
ben ces gens là il faut deux accompagnés
alors ce qu'il faut faire aujourd'hui
c'est aller à leur rencontre
là où ils sont souvent sont des gens qui
savent et qui travaille très souvent
dans le domaine de l'agriculture mais on
en trouve aussi dans le bâtiment on en
trouve aussi évidemment dans le domaine
du tourisme
enfin dans tous les secteurs aller au
devant de ces gens là il faut leur
expliquer comment ton se régularise en
terme économique c'est à dire comment on
ouvre un kbis il faut les accompagner
dans la méthode pour qu'il comprenne
comment ça fonctionne les accompagner au
début pour leur expliquer comment ils
payent leurs charges il n'y a pas
beaucoup de charges et à 8% ou 14% dont
leur expliquer la vertu à payer ses
charges là et d'ex effet au moment où
ils ont fait la l'inscription alors à ce
moment là il faut qu'il soit érigé tout
de suite également aux 1500 euros donnés
aux petites entreprises
et là il faut pas que les petites
entreprises qui aujourd'hui ont fait ce
pas d'être déclarés soit en opposition
avec ceux qui ne le sont pas encore il
n'y a pas aujourd'hui de compétition
dans la misère aujourd'hui on a un
problème majeur le point majeur c'est la
survie du tissu économique de nos
territoires
donc on a besoin aujourd'hui de
solidarité on a besoin aujourd'hui que
personne ne soit laissé sur le bord du
chemin
et moi je dis que c'est une opportunité
aujourd'hui fantastique pour permettre à
ceux de qui était dans l'ombre pour
permettre à ceux qui étaient finalement
exclu d'un système comme le système des
retraites il faut leur permettre
aujourd'hui de venir
en accompagnement de l'effort national
pour ça il ya des gens qui savent très
bien faire ce type d'accompagnement je
pense à la 10 l'adie connaît bien ce
genre de petits opérateurs la différer
travail fantastique depuis des années et
des années et des années
il faut permettre à l'as dit d'aller à
la rencontre de ces opérateurs parce que
elle elle peut plus facilement les
approcher et là les réseaux sur place
une structure comme et rénove une
association commérer d'homme peut aider
également à aller vers ceux se ses cette
approche nécessaire pour qu'on arrive
progressivement à faire en sorte que
chacun entre dans le cercle vertueux
économique national donc il faut tendre
la main à ses petites petites
entreprises et il faut que absolument il
soit éligible
aujourd'hui aux amortisseurs économique
car nous avons besoin d'elle
nous avons besoin de ces gens là nous en
avons besoin
où